le retour du dindon sauvage en amérique
du nord est l'un des beaux succès de la
conservation
mais cette renaissance pose la difficile
question de la cohabitation avec les
humains alors comment concilier les
avantages économiques liés à la présence
du dindon on n'a qu'à penser à la chasse
avec ceux de l'agriculture
[Musique]
voici un des plus gros volatile sur le
continent le thym sauvage est reconnue
pour être une bête rusé et très
difficile à chasser mais sa plus grande
qualité reste son extraordinaire
capacité d'adaptation
après avoir frôlé l'extinction le des
noms sauvage fait un retour en force
partout en amérique une colonie ce même
le québec
une région qu'il n'avait jamais
fréquenté mais l'essor fulgurant du
dindon cause de plus en plus de
problèmes
[Musique]
les réseaux sociaux illustre bien tous
ces conflits sur les routes
comme en ville mais c'est à la campagne
que la présence du dead on pose le plus
de problèmes le dindon s'attaquent aux
cultures cac sont près des récoltes du
jeu mou j'envoie 50 cède 1,5 à in love
symbol est bon d'en manger tout en plus
fait clairement dit il ne rêvons tous
moi je chante je dois faire quelque
chose pour protéger mon bétail se doit
les tirs et je dois les éloigner a
appliqué promo avec le tendon sauvage
est elle en voie de devenir venait d
érable histoire des premiers dindon
sauvage au québec a peut-être commencé
sur ces collines du pontiac en outaouais
il ya 30 ans
aujourd'hui l'outaouais est une des
régions qui comptent le plus de des dons
québec
à 24 heures de l'ouverture de la chasse
au dindon le biologiste andré dumont
multiplient les patrouilles sa région
présente un des meilleurs succès de
chasse au québec on estime ici qu'on
environ 1/3 même chapeau sur les
quatorze mille donc peu plus de 25% des
femmes il faut dire que la région offre
tout ce dont le dindon a besoin ici on
retrouve un très bon et vitaux pour le
dindon dans le sens qu on a de la
nourriture à proximité du couvert donc
ici on a un champ de sayo qui a été
récolté l'année passée puis à proximité
de cette nourriture là on a une forêt
mature donc décidé de re 3 des sites
découverts puis en plus on a à côté on a
un joli saut donc souvent on va
retrouver les groupes de demain dans un
staline ashton la nourriture un couvent
un cours d'eau l'espèce est aussi très
prolifique et semble bâti pour coloniser
de nouveaux territoires
un exemple andré dumont voix nancy
broussailles un site de choix pour la
niche et souvent ils montrent une
dépression comme ça au pied d'un arbre
des graminées auto puis vont installer
unis à même le sol ils vont pas en une
douzaine d'heures à raison d'un par jour
une fois que les douze ventes attendues
vont s'installer sur les nids pour une
vingtaine de jours
à l'arrivée des premiers colons en
amérique le dindon est absent du québec
mais bien présent dans une quarantaine
d'états américains l'espèce devient vite
populaire
si bien qu'une chasse intensive mènera
le dindon au bord de l'extinction des
efforts de repeuplement de même qu'un
encadrement sévère de la chasse aux
états unis permettront la renaissance du
dindon plus tard le québec profitera du
débordement américains et ontariens du
dindon et dans les années 2000 on décide
de lui donner un coup de pouce des
associations de chasseurs appuyé par le
ministère de la faune capture et
relocalise dans le sud du québec quelque
600 des dons ce qui contribuera à
accélérer son peuplement ça c'est beau
[Musique]
et
cet agriculteur attend avec impatience
un groupe de chasseurs sur ses terres
marion mange on en a assez
depuis cinq ans il voit beaucoup trop de
dindes ont mangé ces récoltes comme ça
devient routine et quand ces rares
titres ou turbo passe errante enroule
bien que ça vient routinier me tuer
il a d'abord constaté les premiers
ravages dans ses champs de céréales à la
fin de l'été mais voilà qu'au printemps
les dindons s'attaquent maintenant ses
jeunes pousses de soja mais il m'a
environ prépare c'est bon c'est comme ça
son soya une fois brut et mûri beaucoup
plus tard ce qui lui cause des pertes
importantes il ya des rendez vous en
conviendrez compte relier déroule ses
mains peau mature c'est même pas mature
30 km à l'ouest de gatineau je tenais à
l'art y voit lui aussi de plus en plus
de dindons autour de sa ferme
[Musique]
ce qu'il cherche à protéger se trouve
ici
l'hiver des dindons ont déchiré le
plastique de ces fourrages pour se
nourrir il craint pour la propagation
des maladies
c'est sur ça mais qui est parce que ça
peut amener des problèmatiques t ils
peuvent faire les excréments dans dans
nos cultures
c'est un nouveau truc que je donne à mes
vaches après on peut essayer de nettoyer
mais on voit tout le temps à toutes les
heures du crunch de da pour moi un joli
piqué ce sujet fatigué travaillent toute
l'année puis apprécier les animaux ne
peut pas trop contrôler qu'ils vont
manger dedans andré dumont est souvent
appelé pour constater les dommages s'il
reconnaît que le nouveau venu cause des
pertes aux agriculteurs il tient
cependant à nuancer c'est dommage on
n'est pas là pour défendre les dindons
mais la réalité c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont attribués aux dindons
par exemple en été les dindons vont se
promener dans des champs de soya par
exemple ils vont consommer énormément
d'un insecte mais souvent on voyait
attribuer de brouter des plans de soyaux
ya un impact socio mais au tout début de
la pause le dindon aurait donc le dos
large
des études américaines confirment que
les chevreuils bernaches marmottes et
ratons laveurs costumes aussi beaucoup
de dommages
oh ceux ci sont souvent attribuées à
tort ou des dents car le volatile sort
de joux lourd et n'est plus facilement
observable que d'autres animaux
[Musique]
mais philip elliott lui est convaincu
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul coupable
l'hiver il voit chaque jour des dizaines
de dindons s'engouffrer dans sa
mangeoire à bétail le plus gros problème
avec les dindons c'est lorsqu'ils
viennent dans les mangeoires seulement
niveau qui devrait pouvoir y aller on
embarque dedans et ils font leurs
besoins poupe
l'idée d'en souligner la nourriture de
son bétail
c'est bête refuse alors de manger ses
excréments
il faut les enlever la paix revienne et
manger le lendemain les dindons aussi on
essaie de lui repousser et il faut
recommencer à chaque jour partout dans
le sud du québec
la houle et des dons prolifèrent les
conflits avec les agriculteurs se
multiplient en 2016
le ministère de la faune réalisé son
premier plan de gestion du dindon
sauvage au québec
si les biologistes voyait poindre les
problème d'acceptation sociale à ce
moment
aujourd'hui on reconnaît qu'il faut
maintenant s'y attaquer
or on manque d'outils pour évaluer c'est
dommage
on est très sensible par rapport à ce
que ces intervenants du milieu que ce
soit propriétaire terrien agriculteurs
forestiers tout ça qui vivent certains
dommages avec le dénonce à l'âge c'est
pour ça que dans le cadre du plan de
gestion de messages 2023 on a un enjeu
spécifique qui aboutit sur la
coexistence avec le déni sauvage et on
veut se doter d'outils pour essayer de
mieux travailler mieux comprendre les
problèmes de déprédations québec
ce qui veut dire où sont ces problèmes
là qu'un commençons preuves sont ces
problèmes là et pourquoi sont causées
ces dommages là en attendant les
agriculteurs sont seuls à éponger les
pertes qu'ils subissent quelques années
j'avais évalué sa entre 1000 et 2000
dollars y at il trop de dindons au
québec
[Musique]
certainement pas aux yeux des chasseurs
le dindon et le nouveau gibier vedette
du québec
[Musique]
après la chasse au chevreuil à l'orignal
celle des dons qui génère le plus de
ventes de permis
on évalue les retombées économiques à
plus de 5 millions de dollars par année
et cette chasse continue de gagner en
popularité
[Musique]
là où les populations de dindons sont
importantes la chasse reste le seul
outil de contrôle du volatile
les agriculteurs réclament maintenant
qu'on ajoute une saison de chasse au
dindon
on demande une chose d'automne on sait
que c'est un plus le loisir mais faut
pas oublier que les cultures et
économiquement si je pense qu'il faut
ouvrir une saison où c'est plus facile
de les chasser devrait faire un meilleur
travail pour contrôler la population de
chevreuils de dindons il ne travaille
pas en fonction des gens qui nourrissent
leurs animaux ce n'est plus un secret
pour personne
québec annoncera sous peu l'ouverture
d'une chasse d'automne au dindon et
contrairement à la chasse printanière
il sera permis d'abattre les femelles
quand on perd mancha d'automne ou est-ce
que les femelles sont récoltés oui on
peut abaisser les populations est quand
même assez rapidement pourquoi justement
parce que les femelles produisent quand
même beaucoup de paramètres de 10 à 12
heures donc quand qu'on récolte une
femelle bien agir rapidement sur la
dynamique de population
contrairement au printemps ou est-ce que
c'est seulement les individus à barbe ce
qui veut dire majoritairement les
marques sont récoltés
[Musique]
le dindon sauvage est là pour rester
l'espèce continuent de gagner du terrain
et on peut même l'apercevoir jusqu'au
bas saint laurent
il faudra sans doute du temps pour
apprendre à mieux vivre avec le dindon
malgré les conflits les biologistes
rappelle que cette espèce doit être vu
comme un ajout important à la
biodiversité région déjà très riche puis
pour les adeptes de chasse ou
d'ornithologie le c'est quand même une
ressource à une chasse additionnel un
paysage
[Musique]